let me ask the biggest possible question
first sure what are the principles of a
life well-lived i think it's to live
with uh with thought that is
to live a rational life to to think it
through
i think so many people are in a sense
zombies out there they're alive
but they're not really alive because
their mind is not focused
their mind is not you know focused on
what do i need to do in order to live a
great life
so too many people just go through the
motions of living rather than
really embrace life so i
i think the secret to living a great
life is
to take it seriously and what it means
to take it seriously is to use the one
tool that makes us human
the one tool that provides us with all
the values that we have our mind our
reason
and to use it apply it to living right
people
apply it to their work they apply it to
their math problems to science to
to programming but imagine if they use
that same energy that same focus that
same concentration to actually living
life and choosing
values that they should pursue
that would that would change the world
and it would change their lives
yeah actually you know i wear the silly
suit and tie
it symbolizes to me always it makes me
feel like i'm
taking the moment really seriously i
think that's really
that's right and and each one of us has
different ways to
kind of uh condition our consciousness
i'm serious now and and for you it's
it's a certain time it's a it's a
conditioning of your consciousness to
now i'm focused now i'm at work now i'm
doing my thing yeah
and i think that's that's terrific and i
wish
everybody took that look i mean it's a
cliche but
we only live once every minute of your
life you're never gonna
live again this is really valuable and
and when people people don't have that
deep respect
for their own life or their own time for
their own mind
and if they did again you know
one could only imagine look at how
productive people are look at the
amazing things they produce and they do
in their work
and if they apply that to everything
wow
you